[Music]
gentlemen
welcome to fight club just spoke to me i
was just really drawn to the thing and
um i'm almost uh scared to categorize
that
the first rule about action films for
brad they're never really about the
action they're a social commentary
things you own
end up owning you for me the um art
feeds off life and life feeds off art
it's not just
for entertainment um it's to disturb you
which it's nice jean-claude van damme
you know blowing everything right brad
and his rip dabs were 37 and in peak
form for fight club and that buzz cut
halfway through the movie that came
courtesy of then girlfriend jennifer
aniston that's right but it would be
five years and his wedding to gen before
brad packed another punch this time as
achilles in 2004's troy
apparently the greeks were naked all the
time then eat naked play naked this is
naked they're naked people they like to
be naked i just didn't realize i was the
only one doing in the movie all the
fight scenes took their toll brad
managed to get injured on set next brad
pitt
achilles hurts achilles you can't do
that headline i'll tell you it didn't
happen it did it it did yeah stupid
stupid twist of stupid iron but the
toughest part of making the movie for
brad quitting smoking during filming i i
think i was homicidal for about three or
four days jen held it together held us
together
she packed for me i couldn't even put a
suitcase together
i like a gun just a year later brad was
an undercover assassin alongside
angelina jolie and mr and mrs smith what
i like about it most it's always like
the relationship or the argument is
always in the foreground the action's
always in the back it's good stuff
when i hit him everybody was like hey
anytime you hit me everybody's
god don't touch her she's you know she's
a lady brangelina would later admit they
fell in love on the set but yeah we all
know how that story ends did you ever
hurt her
i don't think so i think she shot me
once
she did with a blank
who won you or angie do you really have
to ask
really
you